[Musique]
nous arrêtons là notre chemin de croix
chers retraitant il reste peu plus de 24
heures de retraite et je sais que c'est
dur pour
[Musique]
vous alors je voudrais vous poser à
chacun si vous voulez choisir de rester
jusqu'au bout dans cette retraite avec
les conditions qui sont les nôtres vivre
ensemble le service le silence JeanMarc
est-ce que vous voulez rester é à la
retraite c'est a terminé avec
oui vous pouvez répondre oui sans
problème merci Jean-Marc Fabien il reste
encore un peu plus d'une journée est-ce
que vous voulez rester continuer la
retraite oui ouis Simon voulez rester
continuer la retraite oui Delphine
est-ce que vous voulez continuer encore
oui ou Paul est-ce que vous voulez
continuer cette retraite il y en a qui
se battent contre la retraite moi je
vais rester à la retraite Clara est-ce
que vous voulez tenir